good morning today is the start of III
week first thing that we're doing is I'm
hosting the battlefront assault on the
tournament it's a part of PPA play press
conference today so I'm still sleeping
but it's time to go in let's get this we
started
[Music]
I'm gonna go pick up my controller and
I'm going to throw it over to iJustine
and golden-boy and Paul hey guys welcome
to the world premiere of Star Wars
Battlefront two's multiplayer gameplay
assault on Steve we're ready to show you
guys the live gameplay for the first
time I'm your host Ida seed and with me
here today with that Golden Boy and Hulk
a producer from guys will be showing
people going are the droids are attacked
and feed they'll be going all the way up
the main the main pathways where's the
royal palace they need to escort the MTT
tank I'm super exciting and we got a
chance to play yesterday and it's just
really fun to sort of get into this
environment you know it's something that
we've seen in the movies we were
actually in the gameplay don't we just
not done and doing our little lives here
the battlefront 2 and you've actually
worked on the game give us some secrets
that we might not have be sure did you
sign an NDA though we did not rusty I
can't tell you're honest it is funny I
sign the PDF right now Lincoln so I'm
super excited the game was so much fun I
love the Vermont and there's so much
more in it's about a library or like
multiplayer is going to be so fun really
is great I am pumped there's so much I
don't know what all that there's just a
million things and you I haven't seen
you since the last time you're here for
another game several years ago that's
right yeah are you I'm good guys we need
to tell them to start vlogging I'm
getting very upset he goes to all of
these fun crazy events music blog vlog
maybe I don't know we'll see but yeah I
had a good time but I was awesome
working with you again finally after all
these years and yeah I mean hey we did I
I didn't vomit oh yeah we did it was so
much fun I'll see you guys later t3 so I
think that I'm like overkill sometimes
vlogging but jesse has literally taken
it to an entirely new level what you got
going on I got a camera with a monitor
and a selfie stick BAM then I got my
homie over here Zack getting up on the
outside for second
kind of play with ya it's easier for me
three up here anything you guys about
super excited for star with law you know
star would stop the battlefront to would
you think fire
I was definitely spent a lot of hours I
would like this close to getting Han
Solo in the mess at four thousand like
five hundred points I need to file under
one point I can't wait to play as Ray
well I'm still pumped
that's my girl they told me that she was
here today ah is she really cuz I don't
I will fan girl I will hit cry alright
well I was talking in one good
you saw the train wreck I do so some
things happen you know doing a live show
is live the things happen so Jesse may
have you know they threw Jesse he wasn't
ready and I just wanted to go give you a
hug you saw them knives I didn't caught
on you did I recovered but they hate me
now no it's not your fault
life is good now of the press conference
that happened a few days ago we are now
on the show for III is officially here
it started and we're going to be playing
some out of art school the only time I
got sleep a few days before they
actually announced it and that was
playing against like a 5v5 when it
supposed to be a 20 on 20 so I didn't
get the full experience here we are
we're going to play I got to get all my
battles links like
get ready
[Music]
[Applause]
people
[Music]
guys Lamar here and we are going to be
playing Lamar Lamar's hey we need have a
chat how's it going going great how are
you saying anything it's been a great
III I lost 5 pounds already
that's a new business method go to Erie
lose weight it's great yeah absolutely
so Battlefront - are you ready let me
show you I still played a regular
battlefront everyday really what a man
I'm like you friends yeah look so I
can't I can't wait well you're going to
love it I gotta cancel playing a few
days ago and it's awesome playing is
Darth Maul you basically destroy
everyone
this makes plums oh well collect your
battle points and you'll be able to play
- so this would be great he does like
here yeah you think you got me in so
yeah cool let's do it
[Music]
oh wow
sample
while I support
[Music]
Oh Oh
on 80th time well you have a counter
[Music]
I'm a behind you
we just finished up playing battlefront
2 it's so much fun I look forward to
playing for it it was interesting
because I Utley the post we battle from
one on PC so now we're going on vacation
and I'm right the other day I played it
on film on I was - that woman either way
I love this look more ug coverage coming
up here I will see you guys later
I mean we were mostly forward - and
hopefully I can check it out long so
here I'll see you guys later bye
[Music]
[Applause]